welcome to the Tim Dylan show everybody
summer in full swing here the kids are
at camp no they're not camps are closed
they're out overthrowing the government
they're fine they're making their own
fun they're making their own fun get a
Chardonnay and go by the pool you
deserve it you deserve it get some salt
water some fresh air that salt sea air
take a nice deep breath hot make some
s'mores throw a burger on that grill I
left the desert today to come to Los
Angeles to record and it's about a two
hour drive and in the time I had left
the desert when I got here a viral human
trafficking conspiracy was born
isn't that 2024 yeah it's in that 2020
when I left the desert Wayfarer was just
an overpriced shitty boston-based you
know online retailer halfway through my
drive I found out they were potentially
selling overpriced cabinets named after
human trafficking victims about 72,000
people had tweeted about it on Twitter
and Newsweek it's prompting Newsweek and
other media outlets to contact Wayfarer
and get a response wayfarer of course
claims that these cabinets are not
placeholders for missing children but
they are industrial storage cabinets
that are priced accurately I mean these
cabinets are thirteen fourteen fifteen
thousand dollars but it is very creepy
the names of the cabinets are missing
girls like it says samaya five shelf
uresa storage cabinet what what is that
but somebody on twitter said these are
placeholders they're priced very high
because they're not supposed to be sold
yet and that the names you could find
almost any name because similar to the
way they sell keychains with everybody's
name on
they are trying to establish some type
of database with names or something I
don't understand online commerce that
much but it is a little creepy that you
can find you know they're doing it with
pillows to where you can find a pillow
that's being sold for $10,000 and then
next to the pillow is the name of
somebody who went missing that's strange
supposedly if you put in the serial
numbers to these ads it goes to a
Russian uh goes to Y and X which is a
Russian search engine and you get
pictures of children however supposedly
you could do that literally with any
group of numbers we'll take you to Y and
X and to pictures of children that's
nice is that any group of numbers
apparently leads you to inappropriate
pictures of children on the Russian
search engine Yandex so isn't that 2024
yet you leave the house you leave and
you're in of our Lima trafficking
conspiracy on the way down to Los
Angeles you can't even take a summer
drive without falling into a rabbit hole
of human trafficking you just can't do
it don't even try to do it you won't be
successful how are you supposed to enjoy
the summer whenever we turn is a human
trafficking conspiracy and some of them
are pretty [ __ ] creepy and maybe
they're weird I don't know what's going
on I'm asking questions these are
[ __ ] creepy
coincidences now somebody on Twitter was
trying to explain it to me and maybe
they're right I don't know I ask
questions I withhold judgment because a
lot of people on Twitter are wrong
they're wrong about a lot of things I
just asked a question I said why's
Wayfair selling 10
dollar cabinets named after girls who've
gone missing and why would they our
question are they removing all of those
items from their online store and
somebody responded the cabinets have
serial numbers that bring up suspect
images of kids when plugged into sketchy
rush and search engine but the same
person said basically all of the names
next to the cabinet's you could pretty
pretty much find any name because
they're trying to build some database
with names direct marketing whatever who
knows I just know it's summer and it's
just you got to just go out there and
enjoy some some fun summer activities
can't be cooped up with a human
trafficking conspiracy for the entire
summer just can't do it
gotta get out there and enjoy yourself
go out to that you know beach it may be
open I don't know if it's open or not I
I've rented a house for two months in
the desert in the desert you know
hundred and ten degrees every day a lot
of UV light coronavirus not living many
things not living the only thing that
can live there is gays and Jews and
tarantulas those are the only things
that survived lizards Jews and gays not
saying that Jews are lizards don't go
and play with the words saying those are
the communities that have thrived in the
desert historically but I'm out there
and I've got a nice home there for two
months and a friend of mine called me
goes you should have a party you're
gonna have a party what party
forget coronavirus forget the pandemic
forget that somebody ate a bat or
Chinese nano robot escaped from the
defense by the defense lab in Wu Han
level for security whatever forget all
of that I'm 35 what party am I gonna
have what gathering of people
would be appropriate at my age given the
current climate of the world parties are
supposed to end their fun in the
tic-tock days when you're in your late
teens in your early 20s or mid 20s party
on [ __ ] yeah beer pong let's get [ __ ]
up blast the music we're gonna live
forever have you seen or been to a party
where people are in their mid 30s it is
a nightmare
it is a nightmare of anxiety-ridden
people walking around all armed with
statistics like their cable news anchors
trying to get their point of view out
it's an absolute utter nightmare to have
a gathering of people at your home when
they're in their mid-30s because there's
two option number one if it starts to go
the route of like everyone's really
hammered and dancing and having fun it's
even worse because you're looking at all
these people and you're like god these
people are on the brink
if you ever see somebody in their mid or
late thirties really partying really
[ __ ] up really getting into it it
means they're on the brink it means
they're about to get in their car and
drive it into a school bus and if
they're not [ __ ] up and drinking
they're like they're like feeling each
other out seeing who's done what with
their life
it's this weird anxious jockeying for
position how are you doing how are they
doing and now everybody saw about
politics everybody wants to talk about
politics if you invite them into your
home they want to talk about politics
for hours and hours on end they don't
want to shut up they come armed with it
with with talking points so while you're
cooking a burger you listen your
friend's girlfriend rattle off
statistics about unemployment you don't
need this this isn't fun there are no
parties anymore go away everybody
figured out while wearing masks not
wearing masks
about your unhealthy addiction to people
how about that how about your disgusting
and filthy need to be around other
people all the time that is the problem
forget the mask don't wear the mask and
leave everyone else alone it is your
[ __ ] need to be in a group of people
all the time that is impoverishing this
country you you can't be alone you can't
be in a relationship you can't get a
hobby you can't do something without
anybody else you need to be in groups of
people talking about what movies stay
home or go somewhere alone a party to be
my worst nightmare a party of people in
my backyard that I've rented to be alone
and sit out in the desert and die that's
what you pay for you pay to get the [ __ ]
away it's end times we're gonna have an
event we're gonna grill hot dogs and
talk about the anarchists in the streets
there's nothing to do anymore folks get
laid get food and get away the problem
with this country is nobody can nobody
can be alone for five seconds
that's why corona virus is spreading all
over the place because nobody else -
nobody can just sit everybody has to be
in a large group of people I don't want
these people in my home I don't want
them coming in forget their disease
they're vectors of disease forget all of
that I don't want their [ __ ] I don't to
be bombarded by their thoughts when
you're on the phone with somebody can
get away go I gotta take a shower I
gotta go call drop sorry
see boom they're gone the phonons
they're gone it was like they were never
there if they're at your property eat
the whole the whole thing's a [ __ ]
process of getting them in and then
getting them out again oh good no no no
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah what were you
saying you know what we sing about the
cops or the racism me yeah I know the
potato sounds good what we're saying
about the the prison industrial complex
right right right I enjoy the party
party time right now I understand drug
legalization no we do need it nightly
right no yeah no we need a multilateral
coalition you're pickles please I want
pickles on that uh how about no how
about no keep them at bay keep them at
bay do a nice little summer alone I'm
telling you go go get a shack somewhere
and shuck oysters
for three months alone read a book all
the shows are canceled by the way all my
August shows a canceled Salt Lake
Ontario and Cleveland sorry about that
it's the way it is those counties are
spiking I'm not gonna go I don't know if
those clubs are gonna be open but I'm
not gonna promote shows confidently
where I think there's a good possibility
they won't happen so when I go back on
the road I'm gonna go back on the road
with a new tour name dates that I know
are actually gonna happen
and it's gonna be an official thing it's
not gonna be like dipping my toe in the
water and coming out and also comedy
only works if you're doing it so if I'm
not getting up every night in the Comedy
Store and I'm not working the improv and
I'm not working well these other clubs
I'm not I'm not you know in in the right
type of shape comedic ly that I need to
be in so it's not fair to ask you to pay
for tickets now I know a lot of people
are performing on porches and backs of
pickup trucks and outside diners in
parking lots because they're mentally
ill this is unmasked a lot of people as
insane okay heroin addicts
have more dignity than comedians right
now performing in parking lots it's the
fact it is a bad look it is [ __ ]
tragic go on la oh stop with the
imaginary gatekeeper that's keeping you
from succeeding go on let all these
female comics you I want the best for I
want the best for I don't harass you I
don't try to sleep with you I talked him
very few of you only millionaires that's
the rule because I don't want to harass
anyone sexually so what I do many of
them go online and they're like I wonder
if when comedy comes back the
gatekeepers are gonna be the same the
gatekeeper is your phone it's the
Internet what's going on is when you're
about to do something funny online does
a man come in and smack the phone out of
your hand is that what's happening
because that might be a bigger problem
that's a home invasion that could be
battery but I think maybe some of you
just aren't being that funny and you're
angry because in your head there's an
imaginary person that's keeping you from
the level of fame you feel you should
rightly have take some responsibility
for your own life and do something
enjoyable do something for Christ one
[ __ ] time that other people enjoy try
that try it just try it it might be a
bountiful it might yield you some real
good results just for once in your
[ __ ] life do something that someone
else giggles at and perhaps that will
take you to the place you want to go I
don't know I'm just throwing out life
advice because I want the best for
everybody that's not only female comics
male comics feel that way too we all
know male comics or losers we all know
that trust me if you doubt that you
could see them performing right now you
know on a literal pile of compost
we get it but I just this was
specifically I saw a female comedian
tweet that about the gatekeepers
everybody's with the gatekeepers there
are no gatekeepers go online and figure
it out or don't it's not it's not
somebody else's fault you don't get you
know Cameron Kowski one of the children
who we are listening to now because they
were involved in the parkland melee
Cameron Caskey go to his pinned tweet
this is amazing
his pin tweet is there's Cameron Cass
Keegan he goes I've always wondered what
a quote real job is when people tell
artists slash creative people to get one
I think I boiled it down to a job you do
not enjoy correct yes get a job that you
don't enjoy until you can have a job
that you do enjoy that is pretty [ __ ]
simple Cameron we all can't pay for a
bunch of delusional Psychopaths who
think they're creative people if I
thought I was a model well it would be
wrong of me to for society to subsidize
that pursued it would be wrong I think I
boiled it down to a job you do not enjoy
correct you do not have a right to enjoy
your job okay that's not part of the
game here I just want to enjoy my job I
just thought of make a difference and
enjoy my job I was watching that show
and this underscores what's wrong with
that generation of Zoomers is that it's
it's some of the right ideas and
absolutely none of the [ __ ] grit and
determination that you would need to
make any of those ideas a reality at any
point and and and this is just a problem
with that generation and I don't want to
sound like that guy I don't want to be
like that guy that's well [ __ ] on tick
I don't shoot on tik-tok because it's
not my place to [ __ ] on tic-tock
tic-tock is 19 year old kids they're
jumping around the dead do I get it no
do I understand why people are are
lip-syncing songs and other people wrote
or they're lip-syncing Donald Trump and
Hollywood is saying that they are a
genius I don't get it I'm confused but I
don't [ __ ] on it constantly because
nobody needs a fad 35 year old [ __ ]
on what kids are doing this is just what
kids are doing okay and a lot of my
friends are like so excited about the
tick tock ban all these like failed
comedians or like hobo tool for tick
tock tick tock bad haha kids it's like
those kids never have to work again for
a day in their life like the tick tock
kids and really establish themselves on
that platform have so much money that
they don't have to do anything they have
six-figure deals
maybe seven-figure with brands they have
endorsements they're good they're good
like one of my friends from Long Island
secured all those two Toads
you're gonna have two good jobs or
MacDonnell's I'm like no I don't think
so many of them have more money than you
will ever see in your entire life this
is the same friend who was asked me if I
was getting unemployment I'm like we're
doing okay the show was doing okay they
don't understand what podcasts are in
Long Island they have no idea they'll
figure that out in ten years like we
have a podcast it's doing well
whoa are you doing you can't perform so
you got do you go to all appointment
like yeah we I don't need it oh this is
the dog curds they did dog kids they're
gonna learn a lesson yeah they're gonna
learn a lesson huh many of them have
already learned the lesson it and is
called they're rich and some of them are
migrated to some other platform will
they'll do more meaningless horseshit
and make
money this this the very childish notion
that people seem to have that it all
evens out that's my favorite childish
notion that people have no they're all
evens out in the end
ah no it doesn't in fact statistically
it does not that's a case you could win
in court provably it does not all even
out in the end ah no no mediocre
talentless hacks thrive make millions
and millions and millions and millions
of dollars talented people die alone in
the street like dogs and somewhere in
the middle you figure out where you can
etch out a career but this whole thing
like it Eve it just evens out in the end
these tick stalkers are gonna be at
mcdonnell's yeah I bet you're gonna work
at McDonald's before they do trust me I
can't you know I can't understand I
didn't start a tick-tock people upload
clips from this podcast and put them on
tick-tock I did not start one I did not
really go on snapchat I had an account
for a minute and I didn't use it I
didn't go on vine I I don't always jump
on the new app some people do some
people get a following doing that Chris
D'Elia got a following on vine before he
moved to UM stand-up and whatnot um I'm
not seeing him because it's I'm saying
he got a following on vine what do you
want me to go um but I I haven't gone on
those apps and I and I stay away from
those apps because I just don't I don't
if if something doesn't strike me
immediately as funny I'm not gonna do it
nothing really on tick-tock is that
funny other than just crazy people like
random crazy people they're funny but
you know people with the dancing is not
you know she's not funny shut it all
down if you're gonna ban tick-tock
get rid of all that banned Twitter ban
Facebook Instagram snapchat ban at all
let's go back to fighting with our
families people that we know I'm for it
I'm for the social media ban if we're
gonna ban tik-tok because it's Chinese
spyware let's ban them all because
they're American spyware get them all
what is it fine I like Martin I like
Mark Zuckerberg to spy on me and not
these goddamn Chinese I want to get
spied on by Mark Zuckerberg that creepy
alien I want him to sell my information
not these try coms Chinese communism is
evil but I like the American
surveillance state just fine thank you
very much huh lock my surveillance
American yeah great the Tim Dylan show
is brought to you by manscaped you know
what manscape means it's a perfect thing
it's a great way to trim your pubic hair
you know I mean I just can't with the
Bush and then this and that let's just
say what it is it's got 9,000 rpms motor
power 360-degree rotary tool blade
system it uses kin safe technology its
intelligently contour design enhances
the trimming experience plus is
waterproof you can do it in the pool use
it in the shower for easy use and
cleaning the only the only nose hair
trimmer on the market oh [ __ ] it's it's
for you dick get 20% off and free
shipping with the code what is it
Tim D Tim D at manscape calm 20% off
with free shipping with the code Tim D
in manscape calm okay it's about
whacking your weeds it's time to look
forward to delivering maximum confidence
while providing hygiene if you need one
of these it's the best on the market it
supports our show promo code Tim D you
get 20% off free shipping it's very easy
I would you've got to do it you'll love
it get involved get into it
manscaped dot-com 20% off free shipping
Tim D thank you
of course very happy again that
the show is brought to you again this
week by [ __ ] comm which has decided to
send these things to us to show to you
which is great I am a skateboarder many
of you don't know that about me but and
what's cool about this is actually cool
there is a a syringe going into a rat
and the rat says oh [ __ ] not another
[ __ ] test which is kind of fun so
that is fun imagine that as a person and
that's Bill Gates see we can't build but
I'm a big skateboarder I love
skateboarding dad a Venice Beach skate
park with my friends it's just so Cal
life this grown-up skating surfing then
there's this bandana can you open that
they sent us a bandana too which is
great and the bandana is for this is for
the Crips
there's the Bloods and the Crips the
Crips are blue and this is Madonna
tax cannabis alcohol raspberry Snapple
Bruce Lee cream slices linda lovelace
street fighter LSD masturbation whether
it's a bunch of cool things on this and
so I mean I'm happy with that and then
they have this so you know this is high
beast culture and you know it's every
every every uh every moment of my life
has been on a scale lived on a
skateboard every single moment of my
life every meaningful thing that's ever
happened to me I've been skating loved
skaters love everything about them loved
surfers loved people that wear bandanas
some of my favorite people
you know white guys with dreadlocks
sitting in venice beach wearing bandanas
skateboarding many of them in their late
40s loved those people there's there
needs to be more of them and so if you
go to [ __ ] calm which is a site where
they sell this stuff it's sold out they
sell out all the time because people
want this stuff you know people really
like it they get into it
there's no promo codes no free shipping
no discounts I mean that's how elite
this stuff is but you can subscribe to
the newsletter and follow on IG or
Twitter they have some cool stuff on
their website and we asked them to send
us some of it and then this is what
happened so but I would still go to
their website because there is some
really cool stuff maybe well in the
future make some cool stuff with them I
don't know I mean what where are the
wheels they don't they don't come with
the wheels just the deck and then you
put whatever kind of wheels you want on
it oh I see I do lie I do like the rat
yeah it's cool getting a syringe
I almost wish that was on the front but
I guess he can't
I guess the cooler stuff always goes
every skateboard I had was was it bored
the Tony Hawk cave to me because he
thought that I was going to be the
biggest name in skating and it's kind of
a cool joke and a twist that I am not
the biggest name in skating but I what I
did was important for the culture so if
you go to their website which is [ __ ]
calm and you sign up for the newsletter
what is [ __ ] [ __ ] is a company you
know it's company sells shirts and
skateboards and cool stuff you know
people buy this and then they resell it
a lot of kids making money reselling
[ __ ] because the high resale value
noone store opening equals Wall Street
opening valve for our buyers so they're
buyers when when when that store opens
at noon everybody rushes to it and if
you buy thing you probably sell it for a
big markup right is that what this is
yeah so you sell it for a big markup and
how cool is that why not you know so
this is not what this is not one of
those things where you're like hey guys
here's how to get it for less money this
is a great way to maybe get into the
online e-commerce market by buying
bandanas and then reselling them you
know and you could strategize like a lot
of people figure out how to strategize
on how to cop an item cop in quotations
meaning not the guy who shoots the
unarmed black person cop meaning just to
get items while everyone else is in a
frenzy and getting carjacked by supposed
BOTS everybody complains that the bots
jacked them but what really happened was
they lack strategy and they went in and
got [ __ ] over you don't want to do
that you could figure out this is you
know in all in all seriousness this
might
be one of the only jobs left he's buying
these things and then selling them to
like rich kids so it might not be a bad
idea it sounds fun maybe I'll do it live
in the air one day we should do that
live on the air yeah we'll go into the
[ __ ] because these people don't know
me I
I know beasts I know B so those [ __ ]
little kids I used to live up the house
I'll grab a few of the beasts hype
Easter like what do they like they're
like twelve they don't speak they just
have they just have these big big
sneakers and like hats and they just
stand on a line and they wait to get in
to these stores so I'll just grab a few
of them and give them like adderall or
something and [ __ ] have them just run
this whole table yeah
have them run the table but we should do
that live we should literally go get a
few beasts and then and then go to the
go on to the [ __ ] store and tell ads
have them show us how to do it the high
beasts they just stand there they don't
say anything
fascinating type of person they don't
really talk they just stand in the line
they're all very like they're like
scared they're just like running through
in their head what could happen it's
like before I get on stage did you stand
up or before like you know a runner or
swimmer you're on the starting block you
get it ready to go these people are
thinking about that but on the other end
of that belly shopping and they're like
how do I shop effectively they want to
make sure it's [ __ ] crazy weave it
really is consumerism on a level that is
it's amazing when you see people with
that level of dedication standing in the
street getting ready and it's like and
they're off all right we're gonna we got
a little white one with an Asian one
there work in the back of the store and
then we got one coming to the side we
got one whose father works at Paramount
and he's having an affair and he dropped
the kid off two hours ago
that's we got and then we got another
one coming in his mother dropped him off
as long as he's not doing drugs she's
happy and she encourages this because
he's learning about the Internet all
right here we go we got another one
coming now
it really is you could call it like a
horse race when these little bombs going
to supreme it's a shame it is in same
while we are talking about companies
Dickey's Barbecue Pit in Rancho Mirage
is running a human trafficking ring that
is neither here nor there go to [ __ ]
dot-com if you see t-dot-com
okay and a lot of kids making money
reselling the [ __ ] merch because of high
resale value the [ __ ] pop up got shut
down by the po-leece that's how hot this
[ __ ] is the beasts love it it is their
life it is why they exist on earth is to
go in and to get this cool [ __ ] they do
so cool bin Laden themed clothing which
I like I like that so go to [ __ ] calm
and is there a promo code or anything
just sign it for the website sign up for
the newsletter we did that you could
read the newsletter I'm interested in
this culture get interested in it it's
fun why not even if you're older and you
can't relate to it understand what's
going on out there because there is a
real economic opportunity is arbitrage
this is arbitrage okay you might not be
able to get into the natural gas market
in Kazakhstan but maybe you could get a
few bandanas and flip them all right
[ __ ] dot-com
he's think these are the dumbest like if
you've if you if you know a dumb person
you can I can I can tell you the three
things you're gonna say this week tick
tock is Chinese spyware that's what dumb
people say because we've all known that
for months they'll say something about
ghilane Maxwell again dumb people we've
known all about that for months I don't
know what to tell you I'm so tired of
talking about Callay Maxwell I'm gonna
[ __ ] kill her at this point stop
asking me about I know as much as you
we're waiting and watching together
isn't that the fun of it
no nothing's gonna happen nobody's going
to jail the Royal Family's not going to
fall it's not going to be you know an
unmasking of every Utley pedophile
in the in the world sadly maybe you know
you know people like who I don't know
it's 2020 it's like well sure but I'm
just skeptical about that you know I'm
just skeptical because I've been waiting
for that and everything else for 20
years I've been waiting here for 20
years for anybody to get caught doing
anything again whatever you want drug
running terrorism I mean literally
anything you want any time we've ever
been lied to I've been waiting for any
comeuppance at all and nobody I mean
nothing people just don't care after a
while the queueing on people aren't
gonna care they're ready trying to get
rid of Trump the Supreme Court ruled
that he's not above the law and then
he's got to put out his tax returns
money has turned on Trump money for a
while was riding with him because
everybody's 401ks were fat the economy
was okay he was navigating us he kept us
out a few wars there people were kind of
like okay um you know now they're
dumping him they're dumping him because
the Econo this pandemic the economy is
just in a state of just it's like when
you when you're when a wave smashes you
into the the sand and you keep trying to
get up in the way it keeps hitting you
and keeps hitting you that's the economy
right now restaurants are opening buying
a bunch of food than having to throw it
out and closing again
and so money and the suburbs I talk to a
lot of people on the suburbs they're
starting sour on Trump too because
they're going this is not good they're
like this is not good Trump Wilkie was
hardcore supporters and I mean Biden is
a corpse so the only thing that might
turn this around is a debate where Biden
you know is is in such a state state of
cognitive decline that he has to be
taken out of the race but other than
that Trump is in trouble he's in deep
trouble because I think the
institutional money and even the top
Republicans I think they're saying like
okay we've had enough we've had enough
here
you've had your fun you've had your fun
we have the pandemic and the Civil War
and the unrest and Americans can now not
travel anywhere they can't leave the
country so thank you for coming we
appreciate it uh we did have fun there
were some moments of genuine levity we
enjoyed it you you seem to be enjoying
it at a few points as well sir but now I
think it's time to move on and go back
to someone boring and half dead and we
can all agree that your biden is boring
and half dead and that's what we need to
go we need to go back to where every
situation in life is not a 24-hour cable
news show we're a conversation with my
aunt is not a 24-hour cable news show
where I have to have statistics and
talking points every time she picks up
the phone and I'm like well actually in
Texas the hospitalization um
it's declined but the death is we can't
do it we can't go on like this forever
we have to go back to something that's
more like normalcy we have we can't do
it people are exhausted everybody you
know now is a pundit politics is for
losers haven't we explained that is it
could that not be more clear to you
every now and that in politics somebody
gets in who's like a good-looking winner
and then they become the president and
then they try to change things and then
they get shot in the head while her him
and his wife drive through Dallas but
for the most part the people that write
about politics to people that obsess
about politics all they are losers they
cannot get laid they have no friends
they don't make any money they have zero
capital anywhere in their life financial
social and they spend their time
figuring out why why am i a loser and
then that leads them down whatever
rabbit hole whichever wherever
gonna go and they're just losers nobody
wants to be these people you don't so we
need we need to get away from the idea
that like people should be consumed all
day with about with their political
identity there's more to life there is
more to life than politics truly not
saying you you shouldn't fight for
things you believe in but you're also
not fighting for anything you believe it
you're pretending so there's more to
life go out take a bunch of shrooms sit
on a hill have a good grilled cheese
sandwich pay someone to jerk you off at
a bus stop I don't know it's not my
business
but there's got to be more to life then
debating obscure German philosophers and
we know what you're doing there or
[ __ ] you know talking about critical
race theory I'm sick of the free speech
tube am sick of that I'm sick of the
canceled culture horseshit on both sides
I'm sick of idiots like Acacio Cortez
being like real council culture affects
anti-imperialists and Palestinian
advocates and I'm like [ __ ] you don't
think Google and [ __ ] Facebook are
gonna sense them you don't think they're
gonna censor Palestinian advocate what
do you what is wrong with you [ __ ]
weren't you [ __ ] saying you're Jewish
the other day she'd pull up that clip
where a OC I don't know if he can't even
find it she's talking to some group but
she says she's a little Jewish so they
cut it out a OC yeah welcome to the
tribe AO sees Jewish background like can
we stop yeah
she's she went and she was talking to I
think a Jewish group and and she says
you know play this clip here this fraud
and one of these that we discovered
about ourselves is that very a very very
long time ago generations and
generations ago my family I sense that
these people are frauds what is wrong
with you they're actors they are frauds
she's claiming to be a bagel and then
she's going to hang out with a lot of
Omar and never heed mine cop they don't
believe in anything
they're frauds you people put your
stocking she's hot if she looked like me
she'd be another loser socialist in a
basement right now talking about capital
but she looks like her so she's on
television every 36 seconds let's not
get it twisted she's full of [ __ ] she's
in front of a Jewish audience and all of
a sudden it's Jews and then the next
time she talks it's like it's about the
power staying out it date it's stopping
you're gonna let these people run your
life you're on earth for a certain
amount of time and you're investing in
that you're investing in this these are
the types of people you're investing in
or Trump was they dancing with Epstein
like this for 30 years and then decides
that he doesn't know who he is
these are the people that you're gonna
spend your time investing in what what
kind of perpetual state of [ __ ]
childhood Peter Pan syndrome is this
where you spend your entire [ __ ] life
listening to these goons all the [ __ ]
they want to do is get power and you
give it to them so easily they all
thrive on attention she that complains
about canceled culture doesn't exist
she's like I've got a white supremacist
television network [ __ ] on me every
day
which he said under Twitter you know
I've got a white supremacist now she
goes I've got a cable network and a
white supremacist TV host that and all
of their fans threaten me with deaths
and everything like that okay and I want
to say something it is it is fight here
I'll tell you exactly what you watch
because I have an entire TV network
dedicated to stoking hatred of me a
white supremacist with a popular Network
show regularly just towards me this is
[ __ ] up do you know what she's talking
about she's only been HGTV that attacks
this woman constantly go to HGTV's
website right now
HGTV has engaged in a pretty sick white
supremacist campaign against a OC it is
disgusting and I don't want to be a part
of it anymore and if you watch HGTV
you're part of the [ __ ] pub please
stop doing screenshots at the audience
getting here jesus [ __ ] christ
look at the lineup of shows on this this
[ __ ] dog whistle white go to shows
please can you handle that go to shows
what's on tonight it's all white
supremacist television all they talk
about is houses you know who owns houses
white people and they'd bring decorators
in to make them look even more white
okay let's my lottery Dream Home let's
look at the let's look at the [ __ ]
let's look at the titles of the shows
Utah Mountain dream home huh Nelly and
Pablo were married for just a few months
I bet Pablo is white Nelly and Pablo
were married for just a few months when
they won 1 million dollars in the
Wyoming Powerball now the Wyoming
Powerball is run by the Klan now they
could afford their dream home in the
mountains of Utah diverse and they're
looking for places picking up for their
whole extended family militia interior
designer David Bromstad white
supremacist joins the couple in their
house hunt along with their teenage
niece Shanna
yeah who has some ideas about what kind
of house is suitable for her millionaire
relatives oh I bet Shania has ideas this
is the network that has been attacking
air-sea since she declared her candidacy
to run and it's a little disgusting and
I sympathize with her I sympathize with
her who is the white supremacist host
that she's talking about on HGTV I'm
trying to find out who it is
is it the propertybrothers is it David
Bromstad yeah this is yet here's the
host of his own television show Color
Splash what with David Bromstad as well
as Color Splash Miami where they just
you know what that show is they go up to
people they go what color do you like
and they go what and then they go too
late and then ice puts him in a van
that's color splash Miami it's called
ice puts you in a van he also hosts
HGTV's my lottery dream home in which he
helps lottery windows fun see this is
funny because obviously I'm trying to
kid around because I know the AFC is
talking about Fox News and I'm saying
she's talking about HGTV but what's even
funnier about this is there is actually
a shop Ben why do you can't why do you
always [ __ ] up stop touching it if I'm
talking about something why are you
clicking off what I'm talking about if
this is your one thing here please Jesus
Christ um Ben was working at a pet store
two years ago and he's gonna go back
there he's gonna go back to getting
people [ __ ] kibbles and bits stop
touching the [ __ ] computer Christ he
also hosts HGTV's my lottery Dream Home
in which he helps local lottery winners
find their dream real estate bro that's
how bad things have gotten that they're
literally have to go to lottery winners
now because no one has any money to buy
any properties so it's like David
Bromstad is is now going to be showing
lottery winners how to buy a property
because these are like garbage white
trailer trash who want to scratch off
and now this guy's gonna take them
around help him get a lake house they've
probably got nine years left to live and
David Bromstad is going to show them how
to get a property my lottery Dream Home
that's great it'll be my lottery leg
soon dr. David helps you choose your leg
congratulations you get a new leg people
gonna sit home and eat popcorn and watch
other people get operations my lottery
kidney next on HGTV my lottery pancreas
where you get an operation you won the
lotto you're entitled to a life-saving
operation and we're all gonna cheer and
go isn't that great isn't that
phenomenal but alc is just a [ __ ] I
mean listen man I respect the hustle I
don't hate her I respect the hustle I
respect what she's about but she's full
of [ __ ] hopefully you are voting for us
on tournament of laughs a show we are
embarrassed to be taking a part of and
an all men about what is to come on
network television I mean tournament of
laughs is is really the worst thing I've
ever seen and that is saying something I
mean it is terrible and it reveals how
stand-up comedians really outside of
standup the majority of them have
absolutely no talent and should be kept
in their home by an armed guard so many
of them don't understand what sketches
are they don't get it they don't
understand the concept of a sketch or
the concept of doing something funny
outside of standing on a stage getting
draw you know being drunk on a stage and
asking somebody in the front row if they
like black dick which is again the that
is the you know that is the trait of
many stand-up comedians that's their act
yeah you have a [ __ ] you over you like
black book you have a blog I so now that
they can't do that although I imagine
some of them are trying they've
submitted sketches to tournament of
laughs which is bad so if we win it's
gonna be very embarrassing vote for us
we don't I don't care but I think it
would be fun if we win
then something I've said comes out and
truTV has to take the prize away and the
executives that greenlit the show are
homeless that would be very funny to me
only because I like goofy things I like
fun
that's all so if you want to vote for us
on tournament of laughs you can and by
all means you don't have to it is the
summer I know you've got a lot going on
we're in what round three now yeah round
three yeah we're in round three imagine
that name tournament of laughs imagine
the work that went into that name those
hard-working executives going let's call
it tournament of left how many zoom
meetings did that take before they came
up with tournament of laughs tournament
of no laughs more likely tournament of
laughs because maybe there's one funny
thing that happens so we're just
submitting sketches most of you have
already seen before and if we advance
we'll have to make left to make another
sketch we were driving around an area
the desert thinking about a sketch to
make it we drove down a long winding
road and there was a guy sitting on top
of a mountain with a rifle and it looked
like he was a lookout for something and
I wanted to know if maybe there was a
drug drop something going on it did seem
Shady Ryan so yeah he had a he had a
brand new or new enough pickup truck and
then a tent so if you didn't have the
pickup truck I'm like oh maybe this guy
lives here in that tent but because he
had that pickup truck and he had the
tent I imagined that he was trying to
maybe keep some things cool out of the
Sun and he was just sitting there with a
rifle and then you got a look at him
what did he look like he's half white
half Hispanic Wrangler jeans and he was
sitting on the highest rock with the
rifle and there's no animals so he's not
hunting there's nothing alive about that
yes nothing to hunt so it has to be I
mean we were what a mile down it was
only long I mean it was a winding road
it was a private road there was all
kinds of signs and we stayed on it cuz I
wanted to see the end I wanted to see
where it led to
you know I wanted to see at the end of
that where you know what's going on
there but but we were dissuaded by the
fact that we we did see the guy we got
to the gate we turned around and there
was just a guy there and I think he had
a rifle you did interesting
anybody with any information on that
call Crimestoppers kinds of people to
call Crime Stoppers New York City now
descending get some New York City stuff
up it is descending into a hellscape
very quickly apparently abolishing the
police not the greatest idea or cutting
their funding which is essentially just
cutting the amount of cops at around at
any given time yes areas are often over
policed and the police are poorly
trained and many of the Meridius we've
discussed that at nauseam but a 19 year
old man was fatally shot and another man
wounded early Sunday in Brooklyn part of
a violent weekend spree that saw 64
people shot in New York City 64 people
shot over the weekend in New York City
it surpassed 400 shootings in the first
half of the year for the first time
since 2016 and with 528 by the end of
last month at 205 shootings in June were
the highest for that month since 1996 so
in a month we're back to 1996 it'll be
fun to see how far back we can go maybe
we can go back to 86
maybe 76 but I mean you were racing
twenty years of progress there there's a
lot of factors you have a you had a
lockdown I mean the economy is in the
worst place it's been and the stock
market obviously is fake so it's not
reflecting that but I mean the
joblessness is is I mean everyday look
at the unemployment numbers in New York
only just just Google New York
unemployment I'm curious
because there's also an economic reality
here that is pretty unescapable is that
millions of percentage so New York State
in May in April they have the numbers
that we're looking at fifteen percent of
the state unemployed New York City 18
percent in May 15 percent in April this
is a big problem and then there's a wave
of evictions coming to get on that just
look at the evictions there are millions
of people I think there's seven million
people in America that are about to be
evicted I believe that if something
isn't done to either extend yeah you
Lumi evictions may soon make 28 million
homeless people did I say seven million
well that was a lofty estimate wasn't it
water rose let me take off my
rose-colored glasses
twenty-eight million people homeless in
the US if they don't do something if
they don't freeze these evictions or you
know put out universal basic income ten
million people lost their homes in the
Great Recession so just to give you an
idea this is almost triple that and
we're just getting started
so ten million people lost their homes
in the great reset and I should have a
party we should have a party who's gonna
bring the dip are you gonna bring the
dip or should I have it let's grill some
dogs twenty-eight million Americans
being evicted one-acts are you gonna
throw rager let's throw a rager yeah
that's what we'll do we'll go to all the
30 million foreclosed homes and have a
rager in the backyard go down a little
bit here Benz now afraid to touch the
computer cuz I yell didn't bow he has a
habit of doing it where I'm talking
about something and he just he moves on
to the next thing because he's lost
interest in the thing that I'm talking
about but his job is to anticipate what
I'm going to do and stay there like
Jamie Vernon see Jamie Vernon is the
standard for podcast producers he's
never wrong
and now jogos is little Joe goes
at a more relaxed pace than I do my pace
is frenetic so I need somebody's a
little bit more fanatic Jamie's but Joe
also goes to a lot of different places
and Jamie's very very quick but what Ben
does is Ben just decides in the middle
of the HGTV thing that would that I'm
done talking about it and that I have to
move on because he's had enough is that
is that what happened I thought you were
going back to the a OEC thing so I was
trying to stay with you now why don't
why not open up two things at once I did
I went back right here and then I jumped
back yeah okay but you had to be yelled
at to go back to what we were talking
about I was being very bad he's he's
just he's gotten very very comfortable
and he doesn't understand that he needs
to always focus and be at the top of his
game he doesn't understand that every
every minute he thinks he's on a golf
course this isn't that situation here
okay you got to be tough they're gonna
come for us at any minute T's
[ __ ] how does the eviction
crisis brought on by the pandemic
compared with the 2008 housing crisis
this woman says we've never seen this
extent of eviction in such a truncated
amount of time in our history
just let okay we can go just let the
people stay in their homes
the government should come in pay off
the mortgage banks pay off the
homeowners and let them stay in their
homes and for all you free-market
capitalist libertarian types that are
against that type of action I hope your
home burns down because when 30 million
people are in the street I hope you
enjoy what happens next because I bet
they're not gonna talk about what went
on at the Mises Institute I bet they're
gonna have a little fun I bet they're
gonna grab some weapons and have a
little fun light it up spark it up if
you make 30 million people homeless in
this country they're going to burn the
country down and they won't be wrong so
you don't think it's necessary to help
keep some of these people and their
[ __ ] houses you're out of your
[ __ ] mind and you have a very
short-sighted view of things your
theories don't matter at this point soon
it's gonna go back to the old theories
where it's like if somebody clunks you
in the head with something and you don't
stop them
you're dead those were the old theories
when a guy would just hit you in the
head with a rock and take your wife and
whatever you had not the other way you
know my point right those are the old
theories that we're gonna go back to and
no amount of you know economic theory is
going to stop that people are tired and
they're really tired of debate they're
tired of debate you're gonna get
cancelled the old-fashioned way because
people just start burning down the
suburbs you just going to start burning
down homes if you make 30 million people
unemployed I mean am I wrong maybe I'm
wrong I don't think I'm wrong that's
coming it's coming
we're heading towards civil war but are
you gonna have anybody over are you
gonna have a party do you do you want me
to bring anything to the party yeah a
gun you bring a gun to the party and
give it to me so I can keep it please
and bring jobs for thirty million people
if you're on the way to the party bring
jobs for thirty million people if you
have them and some ice summer's here is
crazy hot outside after a few minutes I
feel exhausted and I'm ready for a nap
between the Sun beating down and the
heat and the humidity dehydration kicks
in fast hygiene is your key to getting
back up and running more quickly than
ever before top performers and
businesses and sports often attribute
success to their morning routine whether
it was waking up early settling daily
goals exercise or meditation but not
everybody has time to do it all with
hydrant you could jumpstart your
morning's and feel great do you ever
feel as Austan in the morning Eve when
you get a good night's sleep you can
follow the best habits in recommendation
but you still feel self starting the
damn thing that may cause actually to
see what's funny is there was to be a in
debate people used to talk this quickly
debate there was a type of debate where
you were doing college people just
quickly think your trimester drink water
throughout the day but it's not possible
when you're not sleeping you wake up
train because you're going
hours without a single sleep Zinta's
running out of my hide you created a
refreshed collection I pounded the bean
mixture I cleared away because the whole
thing about debate was saying the most
in the least amount of time like canning
it all in and it's made with real fruit
trees powder it's delicious they're
refreshing it comes in a wide variety of
flavors including me summer from the
orange mango and for body but it is
hydrants a way to get up without the
coffee without the [ __ ] you get up
you put the hydrant and they you know it
really makes sense people love it we use
it it's drink hydrant dot-com slash Tim
promo code t I am for twenty five
percent off your first order drink
hydrant comm slash Tim and enter promo
code t I am to save 25 percent this is
the easiest way to get up in the morning
you bet you fill yourself with
electrolytes and vitamins and you're not
you don't crash with with a lot of sugar
it's got a little natural sugar you
don't crash with sugar but you don't
crash with caffeine I'm telling you
right now it's um it's so important it's
backed by a 100% satisfaction guarantee
if you don't love it send it back for a
full refund you need to really try it
for yourself to see what I'm talking
about
it tastes incredible and it works
hydrate starts off it's just the burger
burger hydrant starts off as just a buck
for a packet for 30 day supply save even
more with a monthly subscription so this
drink hydrant calm slash t I am used t I
am for 25 percent off your first order
if you want to pick me up and you like
our show and you want to support us this
is how to do it thank you as folks adapt
to the changing world we're all gonna be
buying more stuff online than ever
before if you're an e-commerce seller
are you ready to meet with the demands
of our new delivery culture be ready
with ship station ship station and I
like this product because you can scale
up or down depending on how your
business is doing getting a lot of
orders can be fast and tough but how do
you keep track of who gets what which
ship a seat right now in the economy
should all be trying to rip off the
wealthy people so whatever you can make
some little crafts [ __ ] and sell it
you should be just trying to suck the
money out of rich people shipstation
helps online sellers of any size get
orders how quickly save money on
shipping costs and keep customers happy
no matter what you're selling Amazon
Etsy your own website
whatever shipstation brings all of your
orders in a one simple interface making
the besi I mean you could just easily
like you could put sand in a bottle yeah
and sell it like you know and just call
it Nantucket you know who cares you
could just do like I would do this has
him as a bed as a gag I would literally
just go what will rich people buy and I
create a beautiful website and I and I
would just literally put horseshit
like not horseshit but like something
ridiculous on the website and just like
you know they could just go and get a
bunch of seashells on the beach and put
them in a bottle put crushed seashells
in a boss somebody's gonna make a
million dollars doing this by the way
put a bunch of crushed seashells in a
bottle or something I'm telling you man
he's rich Fox they just want to buy
knickknacks to put on their dressers and
stuff I'm telling you it doesn't need to
be amazing you could do a lot of stuff
no wonder why shipstation is the number
one choice for online sellers you will
ship more and less time with the best
rates available you can try ship station
free for 60 days when you use code Tim
Dylan so number one if you have an
e-commerce business or you're starting
you're thinking of starting one this
allows you the first 60 days free think
about that that's [ __ ] crazy okay
click on the microphone at the top of
the homepage and type Tim Dylan if you
go to ship station calm then enter the
code TI MDI ll o n I'm telling you this
should be something you try to do if you
have any and maybe you're just selling
old baseball cards maybe you're selling
memorabilia maybe you're selling things
that you may can create maybe you're an
artist a painter you're painting pottery
who knows but this is such a great way
to keep track of it all and you get your
first two months of shipping free
there's no other way to do that no other
business manok service is gonna let you
have 60 days of free shipping when you
use it
Tim Dylan and I'm telling you right now
folks I would just [ __ ] try to see if
you could sell some stuff now why not
you know I mean truly why not what is
stopping you from just trying dude you
could sell anything old books I mean
truly anything you could make crafts
maybe you want to get rid of some
cookware maybe you want to get rid of
anything you open up like a like a
northeaster an antiquey store and then
you just sell different types of
antiquey things and lie make up a lie
say that you you and inherited a big old
house and all this stuff came out who
cares make [ __ ] hot make people think
they're getting something special oh I
found all these I found all these
interesting things in this big old
spooky creepy house and I'm going to
sell them to you don't say spooky or
creepy that might turn people I've just
got this beautiful old house where a
woman was better entire life not being
racist so everything has such a good
energy and then sell something I'd just
by God all these I got all of her Forks
that she used to feed her non-racist
little mouths and I'm gonna sell them to
you and I'm gonna use shipstation I'm
gonna ship station calm and then
entrecôte Tim Dylan TI m TI ll o n
that's ship station calm enter code Tim
Dylan t IM di l o ba t IM d i ll o n you
have 2 months free you can try i might
do this we might set up as a gag because
I'm curious literally about what I can
get people to buy I mean so I'm curious
what people will buy on ship station you
know how many times you wash that shirt
it still looks good
a bunch I've won this little bonfire
calm what bonfire calm /t I'm doing on
Friday I'm / Tim Dylan and you GAD all
the merchandise tears well I don't want
I don't want to Jack their ad with our
head but shipstation calm enter offer
code TI MDI ll o n you've got 60 days to
sell people some [ __ ] that's the way
the future man make money sitting on
your butt do it the head of Goya beams
went out and said he liked Trump by the
way who the [ __ ] eats Goya beans
Mexicans right yeah yeah I've never
eaten a Goya bean in my life yeah
they're all upset because the CEO of
Goya said we're lucky to have a leader
like Trump listed a lot of Latinos like
Trump I don't know what to tell you
I'm sure I've eaten Goya beans that
others have made for me I just have
never made a Goya bean this is a Latino
community issue completely this has
nothing to do with me I eat the bushes
baked bean the grill the grilling bean
the grill style I don't need the Goya
beans okay well how do you make them
what do you put them in them in a bucket
with Lysol races joke it's a racist joke
what'll it mean for my career
[Music]
yeah Koya he loves Trump let it be
whatever after experiencing a tremendous
surge of popularity during lockdown
declared by the cut as boomtown for
beans beans now face a devastating
setback Goya notorious and beloved girls
used to a bean purveyor creator finely
crafted legumes that you don't have to
be on a waiting list for us now the
subject of a boycott after the company
CEO lavished praise on President Trump
could we get the video up of him
lavishing praise on Trump by the way if
you think Goya beans bed the guy that
runs Bush's baked beans is highly Hitler
somewhere it will took him to a white
supremacist the guy that's running
Bush's baked beans is 100 percent at
Charlotte's filming a torch
if the Goya bean guy likes Trump the
Bush's bean guy thinks Trump is a
liberal [ __ ]
mr. Goya all he said I don't think we
need to get it all he said is that we
are blessed to have a leader like Trump
make your shopping decisions accordingly
so hey all you poor maids that were
buying Goya beans now buy lobster go to
the butcher and get a nice cut of meat
because that's how boycotts work so next
time remember when you get off the
public bus and walk into the grocery
store don't purchase the 99-cent Goya
bean go and get some Chilean sea bass
and eat that instead maybe Goya beans
are tasty I really never had I've had
them they're pretty bland it's just a
red kidney bean
stavi a lot of protein fiber what the
[ __ ] are we even talking about in this
country what do they do with them they
do they dress them up they do the Latin
cultures must do something to them
salt pepper what does the CEO of Bush's
baked beans saying about Trump Jesus
Christ CEO Bush's baked beans definitely
like V gets invited to the Rose Garden
he's definitely gonna be like Minister
praising it we're a white country I love
my white brothers and sisters Duke come
up here and then the dog gets up yeah
they're like Duke what's going on then
the dog puts his little paw up I
wouldn't I'm not gonna do the Hitler
thing because then they go throw us off
YouTube they're not gonna understand
that it's a joke that I'm gonna have to
explain to a lawyer that I was
pretending to be the Duke Duke the dog
from Bush's baked beans saluting Hitler
in the Rose Garden and we have to
explain why that is we're gonna have to
contact people and just go up be a back
and forth be a real issue so I'm not
going to do that but just imagine just
imagine that how satirical and lovely
that would be the dog from Duke the dog
from bushes huiling Hitler in the Rose
Garden and then the bushes people having
to dress that I have to go well Duke is
no longer our spokesperson
we don't know what Duke was doing and
then a lot of people gonna be like I
think Duke was raising his hand to ask a
question
Duke was just trying to ask a question
and they're like no it was pretty clear
that Duke was heiling Hitler and they're
like no we don't think so
Duke was asking a question and that's
what he was doing and then it would be a
debate but I wish everybody a Goya foods
the best and you know but a lot of
Latinos like Trump I don't know what to
tell you I think he got 30% of the
Latino vote a Latino lot in X lettings
Latin X lot Latin X sounds like a slur
Latin X Latinos support for Trump is a
problem for Democrats that was from
February he got 28% of Latino voters
supported Trump 30% support him now 30
percent of Latinos are apparently white
supremacists man what are you gonna do
folks I extended my rental now I'm there
to LA I'm in the desert until September
1st really try to do something fun will
do maybe alive live in the desert show
or something I don't know like something
something we want to get out of the
studio for a minute where we're thinking
about a studio redesign it's a little
bleak it's a little dark we know we're
trying to liven it up a little more fun
a little more pep in our step it's just
being a little difficult to get
everybody on the same page but we're
gonna we're gonna definitely put
together a a little bit more of a
vibrant color scheme maybe we'll go to
the guy from HGTV I think can he can
show us it we should sign up we should
sign up that would be a great show HDTV
guys remake nazi podcast studios what a
fun show that would be and it's just
like these guys from HGTV to come out
and like so we really love the space and
they're like what's the show about and
he's like these guys in their basement
like pop politics it's about politics
and they're like okay it's like what
about politics anyway it's about some of
the things we believe not being true
we'd like a lot of red because we've
taken the red pill Nazi podcasters
getting a makeover from HGTV they're
dealing in questionable content HGTV is
here to give their Nazi podcast a push
in the right direction which is you just
need a splash of color you just need a
splash of color
you can't rant about the shapes of
skulls in this musty den make it nice
why not
I do like HGTV you know if you get into
a real groove with HGTV you can really
just kind of watch it because you just
imagine yourself living a bunch of these
different lives you know you're like you
can watch an afternoon of HGTV and
basically say I you know what if I lived
in in a South Carolina beach town what
if I lived in Charleston you know what
if I lived in Michigan by a lake and I
was that guy you know what if I lived in
the desert of Arizona like that's kind
of what's fun about HGTV is like you get
to see these real people go into real
houses you know it's not million dollar
listing this is not like come see a
stunning estate this is like real people
that have choices and they can they live
in these like somewhat decent
communities and you kind of see what's
out there you see what's out there and
it's um they're not a sponsor I'm just
giving them the free ad but they but too
much of it is now I like just watching
the show where they go in too much of a
now's like let's flip a house it's like
who gives a [ __ ] just show me things
stop telling me how to do something stop
telling me I'm gonna start flipping
houses please just show me different
things show me things why eat an Oreo
stop instructing me how to be a
State investor just get me in and out of
the houses let me see [ __ ]
let me see [ __ ] let me get to know these
two pieces of [ __ ] that are wandering
around you know Winnetka Illinois trying
to find a property let's just get in and
out here I don't I don't need for you to
tell me how I'm gonna take on a
six-month long renovation project I
don't need that HGTV but I do think it's
[ __ ] up the day attack Acacio Cortez
and I hope she remedies that I hope well
when she's our queen I'm sure she will
we will only have the networks that she
likes you know just be I don't know what
it'll be but it'll be something it'll be
fun ALC she's a fun woman I'd love to
have her on the show I'd love to have
her on the show yeah I do I am
disappointed in her a little bit like
Cynthia McKinney I like because Cindy
and McKinney went like hardcore like we
did 9/11 she was a congresswoman and
she's like we did 9/11 she went wild and
she just [ __ ] it I think she lives go
girl where she lives
where does Cynthia McKinney live this is
what happens when you go wild you gotta
like leave the country where does she
live now I feel like she lives out
I could be wrong maybe look it maybe
we'll get Cynthia McKinney on the show
she's wild
she'll is a Cali saying she lives in
Stone Mountain in California that links
dead dude I think she's like somewhere
else I don't know why she is a
controversial woman look what she's
tweeting right now go to a Twitter says
she's in Atlanta she's tweeting about
Epstein the other day I forget I forgot
what she was saying um let's go back up
go back up she retweeted Trump she
retweeted Trump goes who thinks we
should fire doctor foul Qi and McKinney
retweeted that oh it's a fake account oh
is it
I think she thought it was real though
yeah okay that's a fake account keep
going down see the McKinney's
interesting man she's right she's right
at the point with the far left and the
far right meet and you know at that
point is it's [ __ ] awesome she's just
awesome I don't know what she's what
she's saying I'm sure she said a lot of
wild [ __ ] don't act me on Twitter and be
like go through you don't know what
Cindy McKinney's thought about she's
saying don't take the vaccine fork over
19 yeah she's wild man Cynthia's wild
saying don't take that vaccine she's a
little wild listen to this
alan dershowitz was lawsuit that seals
forever the files containing the names
of epstein clients protecting all who
are black now by Epstein and Mossad as a
result of sexual trafficking pedophilia
and worse that's interesting and worse
thrown a few bones to the cube people
she cuz uh they were blackmailed by
Epstein and Mossad as a result of sexual
trafficking pedophilia and worse what
could be worse obviously it's the murder
oh yeah of the kids Cynthia McKinney go
down what's that what's that [ __ ]
photo picture dude she's going full
covert ruther she's full Cove of truth
or now yeah she is
full Cova truth there is this her
website true news.com go to true news
coms that's Cindy McKinney
I'll subscribe to the site every day of
my life if this is true please tell me
it's like Cynthia McKinney interviewing
Roseanne I'll never watch anything else
his Melania Trump a silent victim of
Epstein's child trafficking network
already I'm like great let's let's let's
read this already I'm in I'm already in
who's true news I don't know I don't
want to play their stuff though now this
is the book they're promoting final
final day ten characteristics of the
second coming of Jesus Christ yeah
alright well we know it's all a scam
that goes back to religion
yeah the queuing on shed is all a scam
that goes back to lining the pockets of
megachurch pastors and a lot of those
guys are only on the internet now
especially because of kovin 19 so behind
all the queue stuff is this real
religiosity and a lot of it lines the
pockets of traditional kind of
right-wing Christian groups or people
very interesting it's just a new hustle
they're like it's not enough anymore to
just tell people about two 10
commandments we gotta we gotta start
weaving together this this
meta-narrative some true
some false build this big political arc
make them feel like you know they are
soldiers in this war and then they're
gonna buy these books and give us money
and contribute to the cause and I
guarantee you that a lot of this Q [ __ ]
is being backed by megachurch guys it's
smart see that's where you gotta get to
in life folks where you're not outraged
by that you just sit back and you go
it's smart gum yep if people were idiots
and they needed something to believe in
and I could rebrand what they all
believed in as something else and keep
finding a way to fleecing them out of
their money
you don't even get mad at it anymore you
just go huh huh that's the reaction you
don't you don't get outraged you don't
start sputtering in at a screaming like
a crazy person you don't show up at
somebody's house and did tell them you
just say you go you know what's
interesting you telling your friends at
night you know it's interesting here's
what I think and that's that and that's
where it dies it people that want to get
involved in this we're just gonna get
involved people who want to give their
money to these people or the black lives
matter people you know for example you
want to give your money to them give
your money to them it's all they tell
you what they want to do they're like
all right this is not really about
police it's about destroying the nuclear
family and instituting Marxism and you
know we want to do that through
controlling speech and you know what
abolish the police we want to lead
vigilantes run through the streets we
want to take everybody's probably that's
what the abolish the police is about
instead let's start taking people [ __ ]
that's not ours everybody's like I
wonder what the abolish the police is
about it you won't work it's not
supposed to work it's gonna work for the
people gonna take your [ __ ] it's gonna
work very well for the people we're
gonna take what they feel is theirs
dummies well I don't know if it's gonna
work just abolish the police it may not
work Oh it'll work it's working already
in New York they're not even abolished
cut their money and crime is up the
abolishing the police is about creating
enough chaos in the streets that you
overthrow the government and replace it
with a Marxist government where
everybody is bought off everybody gets a
certain amount of money and everybody
embraces some type of surveillance state
and we all do this because we want the
chaos to end now the people that want to
bring about this revolution are they
gonna be the people that survive to the
other end of it who knows but that is
what they want they want to totally
destroy capitalism and everything with
it private property you know your right
to bear arms your right to speak your
right to you know own and operate a
business they want to get rid of all of
that your right to worship freely your
religion I mean that that's what they
want to get rid of so I don't give a
[ __ ] about his Q not you if you want to
worship the Church of Qi on as long as
you're not going and kidnapping people
or [ __ ] doing crazy [ __ ] I don't care
what you do it doesn't matter I'm only
on this earth for a certain amount of
time I can't worry about you that's your
journey
that's your journey of whatever you want
to believe and I can't tell you sure
there's a lot of people that are
thrilled believing and queuing on they
love it makes them happy
who am I to say what what you're allowed
to believe it but that the BLM stuff
does a comfortable place where they they
they want everybody to be controlled and
they're using racism as a way to suggest
that nobody can have any freedom because
the only freedom yeah you know the only
reason are the only way people using
their freedom now is to be racist and to
oppress other people so if you want to
give them your money do that go ahead
and give them your money I don't care
you want to give the queueing on people
your money give them your money in it
doesn't matter me doesn't doesn't matter
to me what you do is completely
immaterial but just know that that's who
you give your money to you give any
money to old-school Marxist and you
giving your money to old-school tent
preachers you know megachurch pastors
that's that's all this - [ __ ] is it's
just a rebranding of that and they're
just gonna suck your money the way
they've been socking it they're gonna
give it to
a Republican now Country Club guys that
just [ __ ] you know make money and
they don't really give a flying [ __ ]
about you and that's just a way that
it's the same old story folks ain't not
new that's another thing that's
frustrating about people that just
really dive hard into politics if you're
smart enough your political art should
last about five years about five years
she's really smart people get it done in
two they go alright believe in things I
believe in things oh so do these people
oh well things gonna happen over there
wait what's gonna wait whoa whoa whoa
what's happening hold on hold on hold on
I don't understand I don't understand
this doesn't make any sense why are they
doing the things that the other people
did oh my god oh my god I don't really
care anymore I met somebody I like a
sandwich
all right yeah people do that [ __ ] ha ha
ha oh that was funny
well you know [ __ ] it only got a few
years left on this earth
da da da da dun that's the Ark if you
have any semblance of intelligence any
go bang pots and pans for the nurses
that's what you're doing all your
political tweeting and talking you're
just essentially banging pots and pans
for the nurses you're just banging a pot
in a pan for a OCA so what you're doing
keep doing it whatever makes you happy
but I suggest I'll make a suggestion to
you out of certain point in your life
you just turn it off turn it off mute
turn it off go do something else cuz
you're not gonna want to get on to the
end of your life you're not gonna want
to get to a point in your life where
you've spent all of your time invested
in in a world that was created for you
by algorithms you're gonna want to turn
that off and go somewhere else and I
don't know go kayaking I can't tell you
what to do go get murdered doesn't it
sound like it's more fun to get murdered
go get put in a burlap sack while you
jog go get tortured in a cabin and
murdered it's better than tweeting at
Nancy Pelosi
all get disemboweled by a really evil
person I was gonna say dude but I don't
want to gender the murderer
it's more fun can't worry all the
goddamn time about politics it's boring
Trump's gonna lose biden's gonna win
Ellen's not going to keep doing all the
people that get involved with politics
lack any other discernible skill so what
they do is a revenue up they take your
money and then they don't do anything
because there's nothing to really do the
country is uncover nerble and the only
thing after this is gonna look a lot
worse than what we have right now that
doesn't mean that like you shouldn't get
health insurance and things like that I
think you'll eventually probably get
those things I think you'll get national
health insurer won't be good but you'll
get it as you should get it and there
should be you know coordinated attempts
to to get those things but you can just
vote you could donate money and you
could vote you don't have to live in a
24-hour cycle of you know opinion and
rhetoric every single day of your life
you can just vote for people that you
agree with and then step back and then
you know try to get things for yourself
get [ __ ] on your own don't wait for the
government to get you something
don't wait good luck talk to the people
that are wait still waiting for checks
for the beginning in this quarantine you
know good luck go out and do something
on your own maybe you can't and you know
and that sucks and that's okay too but
like you know you're relying on this
incredibly corrupt government of morally
vacant human beings I mean I don't know
I don't know what I don't know what to
tell you you still think this is all so
waiting on the check like well yeah we
just abolish the police that'll fix it I
don't fix it just get rid of the police
yeah society won't come apart don't
think it will no we'll just we'll just
get rid of the police we'll let
everybody solve their problems on
Twitter social media Twitter will become
real life and then people
well the the reply guys will be it in
real life and they'll reply with a knife
to your throat that's the way they'll
reply to reply guys on Twitter will be
coming and that's what many of you need
many of you need like we need to start
seeing blue checks on Twitter who all
live in cities get disemboweled we need
to watch a video of some of our faves
some of our blue check favorites get
disemboweled and when you see their
entrails on the street you go hmm not
working well but they're the ones that
keep clamoring for it so let it happen
let it happen in New York let it happen
in these cities let T cities burn and
let these people that have all embraced
this idea they gotta live in those
cities man I don't give a [ __ ] I'm the
[ __ ] out of here a [ __ ] out of
California I'm not gonna pay 12% so that
one day I can own a six million dollar
house that's the size of a storage shed
on in the Hollywood Hills it's stupid
it's stupid if you're living in New York
City now you're stupid just leave if
you're in LA you're almost stupid just
leave we're about to really see a
resurgence of other parts of the country
right now let these people stay in New
York in LA let them go to a place take
it over start a scene you know go to
[ __ ] I don't know go to uh try to
think where you should go go to Omaha go
hang out with you know go ask questions
about - whoo - Johnny disappearance go
try to solve that case people DM me new
leads about my kind of guy swings what
ever happened to Johnny Gosch a good
question I don't know where he is
wherever he is right now he's tweeting
he's probably retweeting aoc I don't
even want him to come out of hiding I'm
gonna be mad he wasn't killed I'm gonna
look at his Twitter and start throwing
up I don't even feel bad for you anymore
you know guaranteed and I get it he's
probably tweeting a positive belize
because he's probably where the [ __ ]
the cops the cops you know we're you
know are bad so I get it I get it man
Rogan made a good point it's like the
the the the real woke people are like
those religious people at Game of
Thrones remember the last three seasons
of Game of Thrones everyone were those
religious people were like the black
hand whatever they called it they just
came in and they were like forcing
everybody putting everybody through
those purity tests it's just getting
boring was talking about the same [ __ ]
every this this culture has gotten
nowhere it's just a death spiral the
same bad ideas over and over again so if
you want to keep your sounded you got to
get out you kind of gotta get out you
have to just turn the key you know and
just get out of here because people are
gonna be talking about this [ __ ] in five
years the only difference is is whether
you are listening to it or not that's it
it's the only difference the only
difference is gonna be are you gonna be
listening to it with the business or
with the house or with a relationship or
in in a town you like or you gonna be
listening to it in in a disgusting
apartment with roommates and no money
alone you know that's the only
difference nothing will change nothing
is going to check things are going to
get worse till steadily get worse
they'll have they'll have bounces of
better like will bounce better or it's
better worse but I you know we've been
talking about like I said I was you know
I was I was started listening out stones
it may be 1999 I was on Alex Jones in
the year 2020 very little has changed I
think in 20 years I mean it's still some
version of the same arguments that
people have been having over and over
again you know if you go back and look
at the issues in in the 2000 election
they're similar to the issues that we
have now economic and wealth inequality
cultural issues gay issues abortion you
know foreign policies taking more center
stage now than it was then that that I
will say we had a little break in the
90s from foreign policy being this
dominant issue and then it kind of came
back again
after 9/11 but for the most part it's
been the same types of people making the
same types of arguments over and over
and it's the same power factions
rebranding themselves you know it's the
same for leftists that are now pushing
you know that every branded themselves a
bunch of times and now they're pushing
the black lives matter stuff and it's
the same people on the far right that
really the religious right Christian
Right that have rebranded a bunch and
they're now pushing Cuban on I mean this
is just where we're at was probably not
gonna I don't know what the only thing
that will change any of this is
technology it's the only thing that has
the only thing that's changed anything
substantive lis is the fact that we now
see the effect of social media and
smartphones have on society but but
other than that intellectually the ideas
are the same for the most part not any
new ideas floating around here it's just
the mechanisms by which they go out into
the world are different you know I can't
if I see one more [ __ ] if I see one
more shitty cell phone via phone away
please you rat put your phone away let
people say something offensive to you
either punch them or go and [ __ ] it have
a drink realize they're mentally ill
stop taking your phone out to try to
video somebody that's being mean to you
this girl by the way that I went to high
school with did an article about how
racist restaurants are nice girl black
girl dated a white guy for years make of
that what you will but she wrote an
entire thing about how racist
restaurants were and they're not that
racist go go to eater dot-com I'm sick
of restaurants being racist or something
and I read this and she's like a nice
girl but I'm like I don't understand any
of this
she was like I'm sick of
I will not keep my yeah this is her I'm
through being silent about the
restaurant industry's racism keep going
down here a few weeks ago I watched my
tattoo artist post an Instagram video
about the racism in her industry and I
saw this other person get up on her
horse and demand change in the
equestrian world Thanks imagine that
racism in the equestrian world no I
can't him are you saying that the
equestrian world has some race and class
issues as I rode my facebook ode to risk
the restaurant industry is extremely
racist it's racism is inseparable from
the history of dining out in this
country restaurants here flourished
after the Civil War blah blah blah yeah
we all know this and I agree with her
she's right about this the effects of
discrimination have been everlasting you
know I got it the people were denied
loans blah blah blah but so this is
where it's weird because a lot of four
examples don't strike me as racism but
go on I began working restaurants in
2009 while attending grad school the
first place as sheriff was a corporate
southern seam steakhouse on Long Island
the corporate steakhouse is she saying
the corporate steakhouse is racist oh no
we will hold her to a high standard of
proof here because she's attacking an
institution near and dear to our heart
not long after I started there a
co-worker was fired for using racial
slurs about a black family who was
dining with us a restaurant owner
individually polished every black
employee and the swiftness of his
actions assured me that racism would not
be tolerated nice corporate steakhouse
good right that's good the following
year I began my career in fine dining at
a popular seafood restaurant on
Manhasset ban know exactly which one
this is Louise in Port Washington I used
to like Louise food was okay I just get
really hammered there and drive home
drunk all the time the staff was mostly
bi POC what does that mean by people of
color I think so yeah
bi meaning black indigenous people of
color I'm just curious
or does it mean they were all bisexuals
cuz that sounds like a [ __ ] amazing
restaurant to work out it sounds amazing
if everybody in your restaurant is
bisexual everybody literally [ __ ]
everybody else I don't know why you'd
write an article complaining about okay
yeah I was right black indigenous people
of color
the restaurant had its issues but during
the two years I worked here diversity
was not one of them but when I returned
so so so so so 2008 9 everything's ok
when I returned to the industry in 2018
after a six-year hiatus I discovered
that my previous experiences were
anomalies one evening while I was
training as a server at a farm-to-table
restaurant I asked a trainer she made
recommendations she goes well they're
agents my recommend the octopus because
Asians eat weird food why is that racist
no I'm genuinely asking why is that that
racist well I understand that you're
making an assumption about people based
on their culture but is it completely
incorrect why is that
why I don't understand that's a big deal
if she had said if I if she said I asked
a trainer how she made recommendations
and they're trying to turned around at
her and goes well I just take the child
they threw in the water and make them
eat that because they drown their own
children that would be racist do you
understand so if the trainer said that
that would be a little racist if the
trainer said by the way if she goes how
do i rake make recommendations and I go
just take a [ __ ] filet mignon and
stuff it with fireworks they're not
people that would be racist do you
understand
if I said how do you make
recommendations and she goes who gives
it their [ __ ] insects that's racist
but by saying hey they like Octopussy
like weird [ __ ] I don't get it ok excuse
me I replied sternly which she didn't do
again I love when people lie she tried
to backpedal saying something about how
Italian guys also love octopus months
later I quote one of the managers and
two servers discussing the treatment of
black people as relates to our work
ethic manager implied that there were
times we were treated better than we
deserved because of our skin colour the
two servers looked shocked but either
corrected her being the only black
employee instove caller ID quit
immediately but that yeah listen that
shitty to do and the manager should not
have done that but that evening the
restaurants owner and I had Nonna's
conversation
she advised me to not letting her people
affect my wallet and she had a point
I was broken Livia yeah that's the thing
man by saying that this is like the
restaurant industries races you've had a
few uh even a few run-ins with racist
people but it's also like yeah their
waiters their waiters and waitresses
they're not happy they're not killing it
in life they're away I know where this
kid boarded Texas Roadhouse yeah yeah
yeah yeah this is not the best and the
brightest all the time some of times it
is sometimes people are but a lot of
servers are just a working other jobs
you're going to school that I mean I'm
not excusing their racist behavior but
when we say the entire industry and then
we use examples from one a few chain
restaurants in Long Island everyone's
racist in Long Island I mean Charlie I
stated the restaurant for a year and a
half shortly before my departure one of
my customers a senior citizen grabbed me
he goes you know what they say about
black woman you whispered in my ear you
taste like chocolate he then attempted
to kiss me well this is Alyssa's out of
hand I pulled away but I didn't want to
hurt him
plus they didn't want to hurt him I can
already imagine the headline black
server abused elderly white man at a
Long Island restaurant that's what they
would write in Long Island so again I
walked away but this time I cried in the
hallway while my coworker consoled me
let me was an old dirtbag who's an old
horndog like women are neither a fetish
nor fantasy and into sexual harassment
we offer experience again yeah but if
there was a hot white chick with her
tits out she look good do you think this
guy wouldn't have said something
inappropriate to her as well maybe not
or a hot asian I don't understand you
again this is again she bumps into
people that are racist here one time
when I
funded some guests whom one of these
co-workers presume were Jewish he asked
if I was a black Jew and this is Long
Island member leave move in response and
reference first they came what
Oh and expressed that I stand up for
everyone and then politely told him to
shut the hell up he did but he continued
to be openly racist towards me while the
restaurants clientele was generally kind
they were still middle-aged white men
thinking they were Tupac telling me I
was a pretty black girl they'd ever seen
is that racism and the white woman who
felt the need to be down when I
approached the table hey girl one of
them told me okay hey girl
hey girls racism now I understand if you
went to the table know like yo [ __ ]
what's up you'll wear your man that like
okay one said your makeup is on fleek
we're trying to get lit that's stupid
but it's funny it's like I don't know
what I mean they're drunk white
middle-aged Long Island women that are
trying to relate to you is this really
that bad I mean is that aren't the the
Weig errs in in a brie education camp in
China
imagine them reading this article right
somebody saying hey girl I'm not saying
that there isn't real racism out there
that you're not a but but I mean this is
great this is like if I said that I
experienced homophobia and and then my
example of homophobia that somebody
asked me I've had a boyfriend or
somebody tried to relate to me or was
like hey yeah it's [ __ ] or something
annoying but I don't think I think we're
just reading too much into it you know
well I wish for the best I mean I don't
want it I don't want we can be we can
get rid of that I don't want her to go
through any problems but I also just
don't know if that's a is that real
racism somebody says hey girl I mean she
said I walked up to a table and there
were five white women with dreadlocks
and
do rags okay and as soon as I approach
the table they made these gun songs I
guess they were like that's a different
story
that's maybe a different story here
maybe that's a problem maybe that's a
problem
you know I guess will be annoying if I
was working in one of these restaurants
and I went to a table of straight guys
and they all started acting gay like
you're like stop bad and they just like
yes that would be annoying to me but my
still my bigger problem I would go why
my waiter bigger problem why might when
I'm a waiter what's going on but yes
I'll be annoying I'm conceding that me
annoying but that's not what it sound
like happened if somebody just went hey
girl your makeups on fleek it's just
some old white [ __ ] try I mean a wheel
yeah maybe it was I'm flat you know now
if she went to over to the table and
they were singing like spirituals you
know it would be a problem or she went
to the table and said hey can I tell you
about some of our specials and one of
the white ladies started singing he must
know something
but don't say nothing he just keeps
rolling
yes that would be racist that would be
wrong that would be odd oh man like she
walked over they all just started
singing Old Man River
[Music]
that's rate you got to learn the
difference between what is racist and
what is not racist if I walk to a table
then somehow knew I was gay maybe they
just see me sucking someone off and like
I walked up to the table and they went
into like a choreographed dance routine
and just just started stuffing like
[ __ ] in their mouths like yes that that
would be homophobic you have to really
pick we got it you got it we got it not
hyper analyze every situation somebody
said hello to you the wrong way hello
cannot be the problem here it just can't
I was so nervous I was in that article
she'd been my server multiple times at
all of those restaurants I was so
nervous that was in that article I
thought she was gonna be like a pretty
well-known comedian who used to sell
mortgages went to my restaurant drunk
and said hey you want a house you'll
sign anything you know you people are
like that I understood I was so worried
that I had said something like that but
I didn't a decently well-known comedian
had made very inappropriate comments and
he asked me to get him cocaine and then
said quote can you call a cousin or
something I was so panicked I was in
that article I'm like God I hope I'm not
in that article
she's a good woman I wish for no ill
will there's racists in Long Island I
guess the best thing would be to leave
Long Island I mean that would be we did
long today folks one an hour and 45
minutes you really get you get more than
you should get here join our patreon you
get a free episode every week if you are
a Rothschild member you get not only the
extra week the episode but we do a jumbo
episode at the end of the month for you
as well the patreon at patreon.com slash
the Tim Dylan show we have merged stuff
that were working on right there
life in the big city Dan is wearing the
shirt that's good he did that part of
the job today Ben is wearing a shirt and
you know a lot of cool stuff happening
there's no live comedy happening folks
but you can always find this digitally
new sketches coming out go vote for us
on tournament laughs if we wanted such
an embarrassment but do it anyway I'd
love I'd love to win that show and then
they cancelled TBS and it goes out of
business so that would be great
enjoy the summer it's in full swing god
bless you good luck goodbye